republican congressman marjorie
taylor-green is on trial
sort of
green has not committed any crime but
georgia democrats have dragged her into
court anyway by using an arcane
provision of the law to try to stop her
from running for re-election
georgia democrats are arguing that the
14th amendment bars greene from seeking
re-election because one of the lesser
noted provisions of that amendment bars
people who have quote engaged in
insurrection or rebellion against the
united states from serving in congress
never mind that marjorie taylor green
has never been convicted of insurrection
never mind that she's never been charged
with insurrection never mind that she
never engaged in an insurrection these
democrats are arguing that because
marjorie greene raised questions about
the 2020 election
you know the election where they changed
all the rules right beforehand that you
know that one uh because marjorie taylor
greene uh raised any of these questions
because the horn hat guy took pictures
in the capitol on january 6th that that
somehow disqualifies this popular
congressman from holding office you
probably have not heard of this
provision of the 14th amendment of the
u.s constitution because it has not
seriously been used in about 150 years
hasn't been used really since
reconstruction in the years after the
civil war the union worked to prevent
former confederate officials from
holding office and then since then
the provision has hardly ever even been
mentioned
until now
just this year democrats in north
carolina tried to pull the same stunt to
keep another popular republican
congressman madison cawthorne off the
ballot there
indiana democrats tried to keep
republican jim banks off the ballot
the courts fortunately in north carolina
and indiana were both responsible enough
to laugh this scheme out of court
george on the other hand is letting the
circus proceed
and you know that
the term
1776
is actually a term that's sometimes used
in politics today
i don't know if you've noticed our state
seal here in georgia i know you're not
from georgia but as you can see we we
enjoy our history and we're proud of our
freedoms 1776 is on our state seal right
and it's also a term that's used in
political discourse in america today
i don't use it as a term of violence
but you use it as a term right
so the the democrats if you couldn't
catch what he was doing there the
democrats are insinuating that if you
endorse the number 1776
that you're an insurrectionist
that if you endorse the year of the
american revolution you are somehow an
opponent of america you're anti-american
if you support the american revolution
so imply the democrats it doesn't just
stop there that wasn't marjorie taylor
green's crime was not merely using the
phrase 1776
which as she points out appears on the
state seal no no it goes further she
her her strategy around independence day
was even more insidious
the last thing you say in the video is
we aren't the people that are going to
go quietly into the night you recall
that part
yes
now that phrase we aren't the people
that are going to go quietly into the
night
that's not something that you came up
with on your own is it
i have no idea what you mean well that's
something that you borrowed from a movie
script right
i don't know what you're talking about
you borrowed that line
from the movie independence day right
this is what they're getting around
they're dragging a member of congress
before a judge to
suggest that some of her lines the the
sort of now even cliche very popular
line she's using are from a movie like
independence day by the way the line
goes back much further than independence
day ridiculous as it sounds
this stunt may actually work and no
one's talking about it and it is a major
threat to our electoral integrity
this this
could theoretically make it all the way
up to the supreme court if a lower court
does not strike this stunt down first
it doesn't look particularly good for
democrats who know that they can't beat
margaery green in an election so now
they're just trying to pervert the law
to prevent voters from having the chance
to elect her in the first place but it's
not just about green
and it's not about madison cawthorne and
it's not about jim banks and actually in
my humble opinion it's not about 2022 at
all
this is
so clearly a test run by democrats to
see if they can keep donald trump off
the ballot in 2024 for the same reason
it's an admission that democrats don't
think they can beat him fair and square
it's an admission that they're willing
to bend the law and pervert the
electoral process to maintain power and
dare i say it i don't want to get in
trouble dare i say it
it's an admission that maybe the people
such as green who doubted certain
aspects of the 2020 election
had every right to be skeptical i'm glad
you liked that clip now
ring the bell subscribe get all those
notifications head on over to apple
podcast but if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you